en cette période de fête des morts je
vous propose une balade dans les rues de
lyon au cours de laquelle je vous
parlerai histoire sordide
au programme des meurtres des
assassinats des lieux cachés des
révoltes des pratiques occultes
arrêtons-nous tout d'abord à
l'amphithéâtre de lyon il est appelé
l'amphithéâtre des trois gaules c'est
une construction romaine dédié aux jeux
du cirque notamment les courses de chars
les combats de gladiateurs
mais aussi des exécutions d'ennemis
d'esclaves et parfois c'est beaucoup
plus rare de personnalités de haut rang
c'est ce qui va se passer en 40 de notre
ère l'empereur est alors caligula qui
régna de 37 à 41 ans 40 de notre ère
caligula et à lyon ils reçoivent tollé
mes fils du roi de mauritanie c'est à
dire le maroc actuel tollé mais se
présente à caligula en toge de pour vous
grave erreur de la part de ptolémée car
la tâche de pourpre ne peut être porté
que par l'empereur à la rigueur les
sénateurs ont le droit de porter une
bande de pourpre au dessus de l'épaule
mais pas plus tous les mets suscite la
jalousie de caligula pour cet affront
caligula fort exécuter son invité
précisons un peu les choses qu'est ce
que la toge de poudre la tâche de
pourpre a une signification très
particulière c'est la tribu de
l'empereur c'est un signe de royauté de
prestige évidemment tous les emprunts
n'aurait pas réagi de la sorte mais
c'est le style de caligula de fer dangor
toujours dans cet amphithéâtre les
romains ou fait martyriser en 177 47
chrétien le christianisme est persécuté
par rhum la plus célèbre de ces martyrs
et blandine de lyon aujourd'hui patronne
de la ville et dans l'iconographie vous
la reconnaîtrez facilement puisqu'elle
est toujours représenté attaché un
pilier avec un lion à ses pieds ça vous
donne quelques indices pour la suite de
l'histoire
cette jeune fille c'est une esclave
romaine qui se rallie à la communauté
chrétienne avec son ami potins qui
deviendra évêque de lyon et de la gaule
et qui lui aussi sera persécutés et
martyrisé la belle équipe
blandine elle a bien morflé elle est
d'abord livré aux lions qui l'est pas du
coup elle est remise en détention pour
être flagellée et brûlé sur un grill
comme elle résiste à ses coups et
blessures elle sera jetée dans un filet
et livrer un taureau comme elle survit
encore une fois les textes affirme
qu'elle nous montre d'ailleurs aucun
signe de souffrance ou de gêne et bien
elle est renvoyée en prison
elle est finalement égorgé en août 177
dans l'arène de l'amphithéâtre des trois
gaules à la fin des jeux où elle a paru
son corps et ceux des autres martyrs
sont brûlés et leurs cendres sont jetés
dans le rhône
changeons un peu de registre ici ne va
pas s'agir de peine capitale mais de lui
rester caché est interdit au public
je veux parler des souterrains de la
croix rousse que l'on appelle également
galerie en arêtes de poisson comme
semble évoquer leurs plans ce sont des
galeries assez profonde qui traverse la
colline de la croix-rousse des entrées
sont placés à différents endroits sur la
colline donnant un accès au rhône on ne
sait pas qui les a construits à quelle
époque
et quel était leur rôle depuis plusieurs
années ils sont interdits à la visite du
coup beaucoup de rumeurs liées à des
pratiques occultes voir satanique
émergent en 2009 des archéologues ont
étudié ces galeries il ya quand même un
kilomètre 4 de galerie en tout ça n'a
peut-être l'air de rien comme ça mais
ces galeries avaient certainement un
rôle très important
sans quoi ça n'aurait pas nécessiter un
tel ouvrage on pense que ces galeries en
arêtes de poisson servaient à stocker du
petit matériel ou des vivres elles ont
été construites en une seule fois entre
le 15e et le 16e siècle et serait
peut-être en lien avec la citadelle
saint sébastien une sorte de palais
royal qui se trouvait sur le plateau de
la croix rousse ce bâtiment il a été
édifié par charles neuf il fut détruit
ainsi que toutes les archives nationales
et souterrains cette absence de
documentation fait d'ailleurs leur
particularité
les vastes travaux de construction pour
cette citadelle ont sans doute fait que
la réalisation du réseau de galeries
passent inaperçues aux yeux des
contemporains et soit très vite oublier
les recherches des archéologues ont
permis de certifier que ces galeries
n'avait pas été construite pour recevoir
des cérémonies occultes et n'était pas
non plus des catacombes
notre balade se poursuit toujours sous
la colline de la croix-rousse
ici on se trouve dans une courbe qui est
l'entrée d'une traboules nos travaux les
temps un lieu de passage dans les
immeubles
elle a été construite vers 1840 et c'est
un bel exemple d'une architecture
populaire dit can use arly à l'industrie
de la soie qui a profondément marqué
quartier mais c'est également un lieu
qui symbolise quelques grands moments de
l'histoire du net
cette course appel la cour des voraces
et elle tient certainement son nom d'un
groupe d'ouvriers canu nommer les vans
qui se révoltèrent à plusieurs reprises
en 1848 et 1849
ces insurrections furent sévèrement
réprimée on raconte que la cour des
boras a servi de refuge aux ouvriers
canu lors de leur révolte
malgré ces refuges ces révoltes ont
néanmoins causé la mort de centaines de
personnes
à présent nous quittons la colline de la
croix-rousse et nous arrivons au coeur
de lion puisque nous sommes ici sur la
presqu'île le bâtiment que l'on voit et
la chambre de commerce ou eu lieu
l'assassinât de sadi carnot alors
président de la république depuis 1887
jusqu'à ce qu'il meure assassiné le 25
juin 1894 à cette époque le climat
politique est tendu
il y à des agitations notamment du côté
des anarchistes et des syndicats suite à
l'adoption de lois restreignant les
libertés individuelles et les libertés
de la presse
le lieu du crime a été aujourd'hui
matérialisé au sol par une brique rouge
une brique rouge que plus personne ne
remarque d'ailleurs que se passe-t-il le
jour de l'assassinât le 24 juin 1894 à
lui un banquier dans la jambe
en quittant cette fête sadi carnot et
blessé d'un coup de poignard par
l'anarchiste italien santé jeronimo
caserio ce dernier ne prendra même pas
la fuite et ne demandera pas non plus la
grâce caserio et donc guillotiné le 16
août suivant pour le crime
il serait dommage de ne pas évoquer des
pratiques occultes d'invoquer les
esprits et les médiums dans cette vidéo
je ne vous promet pas de rentrer en
connexion avec l'au delà ni même réussi
à faire tourner dans les airs mon
trépied ma caméra
mais je vais quand même vous parlez de
spiritisme car lyon depuis le milieu du
19e et très marqué par les activités
spirit a lyon c'est alan kardec qui va
terroriser les populariser le spiritisme
mais qui est alan kardec
c'est un instituteur de formation qui se
présente au départ comme sceptiques
lorsqu'il entend parler des expériences
de tables tournantes par exemple un jour
il assistera à une de ces séances
il en sortira convaincu et il acceptera
de synthétiser dans un ouvrage 50 cahier
que des proches lui offriront décrivant
les communications avec les esprits il
réunit dans son oeuvre la plus connue
le livre d esprit diverses expériences
entre le monde des vivants et celui des
esprits son vrai nom c'est hippolyte
léon rivail alan kardec et son
pseudonyme venant d'après lui de sa vie
antérieure où il s'appelait alors alan
kardec et était d'un druide
je pense qu'à ses séances de spiritisme
il buvait pas que de l'eau et mais quand
alan kardec à une grande renommée
internationale notamment au brésil
si vous êtes sur paris vous pouvez voir
ça tombe au père-lachaise qui est l'une
des plus fleuris du cimetière
a lyon on a voulu rendre hommage à alan
kardec en plaçant cette stèle la forme
évoque un menhir puisque kardec était
certain d'avoir été droid dans une vie
antérieure rappelons que cardiaque à son
époque effet l' amalgame entre celtes et
menhirs on ne lui en tiendra pas rigueur
mais si seulement ils pouvaient
communiquer avec nous aujourd'hui on
l'expliquerai que les gaulois ne levait
pas de mes liens les structures
mégalithique comme pu en voir en
bretagne par exemple sont bien plus
anciennes et que les périodes de l'âge
du bronze et du fer et correspondent au
néolithique européen c'est-à-dire 5000
3000 avant notre ère
c'était bien déterminer si toutefois la
guillotine la torture c'est pas votre
truc
bah c'est pas grave y'a plein d'autres
activités de plein air automne et vous
pouvez tout à fait vous contenter de
quelques marrons chauds la musique est
extrait du premier ep de warrants crâne
d'un groupe que je vous recommande
chaudement faubourg est tous les liens
vers leur contenu en barre d'infos sur
ce je vous remercie et je vous le répète
il n'y a aucune peur à voir